so you guys have had great success as a
writing tandem mm-hmm do you think you
could have done it without each other
yeah Horace I'm what oh no no no because
you know it's a it's it's it's a
partnership and a lot of the ideas just
come out of like brainstorming sessions
going back and forth or something's
written and then others we have ideas
and no i don't think so I'd beid be
totally different you know it's the same
exercise if you gave three different
directors the same script it'd be
totally different Jana me and so what we
end up with would be very different i
think because each brings a different
thing to the table well it's a marriage
again and so with each partnership
there's some they're stronger in other
parts yeah and others that carry for
what may be someone who is raisin strong
yet yeah so do you kind of know each
other in that I me for what 10 some
years morning well known each other
longer I mean it's since 1990 fortnight
the 1900s Wow millennium will be bad but
you know the first thing we wrote
together was 99 it was feast in 99 and
we since we both been on LA we met at
Iowa University of Iowa and and I've
been in la since 97 teak about 99 and
and we live in the same building for
years and years and then I actually
started riding on a borrowed computer
that was had this that we could type
faster than I could process he literally
have to let it cool down and then turn
off and way no and then boot it back up
and all right we'll do a few more pages
and that first script we started on
halloween weekend 99 became feast the
first movie that was boats made and that
man yeah i knew we were fortunate then I
did not I don't think I still fully have
a grasp on how entirely lucky we were to
have that experience because there are
there are writers and there are
producers and there are directors that
never gets a chance to tell their story
and we're sitting here today to talk
about the the eleventh
10 and then don't tend to produce film
yeah we got credit for yes and that's
just I mean wow we have stories now to
entertain ourselves well through old age
and beyond
you